ap
[Musique]
oh
bonsoir bonsoir gérard bon choix vous
savez que hier chez madame ce n'est de
paris bien il ya une grande grande joie
car madame sonné à trouver l'église
diabolique pour 4500 francs elle est et
je dois dire très très heureuse et nous
aussi bien sûr pour elle aujourd'hui
notre graal un petit peu moins mais
c'est normal
600 francs la boîte sympathique et 300
francs notre tout nouveau truc au pied
du mur vous savez que c'est monsieur
lafon amateurs qui nous envoyait ce truc
monsieur lafon et professeur de boxe
française et ce truc vaut 300 francs je
vous présente tout de suite nos six
nouveaux candidats notre premier
candidat monsieur le guillon malakoff
deuxième candidat le sumo l'idylle
troisième candidat si pajany
noisy-le-sec quatrième candidat madame
jazz de bagneux cinquième candidat je
suis joueur de charleville sixième
candidat lama giron de ville prend
regardez bien votre récepteur notre
premier truc la boîte sympathiques ils
vont je vous le rappelle 600 francs il
n'y a pas beaucoup d'aller mettre dans
cette boîte
suffisamment pour réaliser un petit os
très étrange
il faut prendre le petit cheveu voilà et
là maintenant arriver à faire monter la
boîte
évidemment si je tire le film le cheveu
l'autre sens la boîte angle au pardon
j'oubliais qu'il y ait un truc
monsieur l'aiguillon avec une question à
poser un gérard pour notre premier truc
à l'intérieur de la boîte il nya qu
exclusivement des allumettes entière
attendez je vais regarder
non non attendez y en a une qui était un
peu abîmée mais ça n'a aucune espèce
d'importance pour le cameroun vous avez
la solution quand vous avez une solution
non non messieurs mali notre candidat
numéro deux il n'y a pas de cheveux dans
le truc
comment n'y ait pas de cheveux dans le
tir il n'y a pas de monsieur c'est exact
il n'y a pas de cheveux du tout c'est un
mouvement demain un mouvement demain
comment un mouvement demain tous les
faits remonter la boîte monte
venez monsieur montrer parce que c'est
vraiment un mouvement demain permet de
faire ça moi je voudrais bien la prendre
venez venez monsieur on sait jamais
peut-être un truc qui réussit mieux que
bien
on est là mais je vous en pris aux bébés
ou si vous préférez cela monsieur c'est
pareil les heures les deux sont préparés
monsieur spécialement attendez vous vous
inspirer des mouvements des reptiles
pour l'instant pour des on ne
travaillait pas dans un zoo non pour le
presque la joie que j'ai bien étudié
dans des bureaux
j'espère vous avez mi temps de répéter
nos petits trucs non savons pas sur
quelle dommage parce que la lorelei
monsieur merci vous mourriez pâté à la
été étonnés l'excusé candidat numéro 3
une question à poser à gérard majax
est-ce qu'il ya que des allumettes à
internet
est ce qu'il n'ya que des allumettes je
peux regarder vous permettez monsieur de
crise à des jeux dans celle-là oui mais
dans l'autre il ya un petit peu de
poussière elle c'est tout vous pensiez
un petit ustensile ou un petit truc h
quelconque longe notre seul candidat de
cette émission parmi tous ces messieurs
madame ajas notre candidate numéro 4 une
question à poser à gérard je voudrais
vous demander si vous allumez de son
brûlé à l'intérieur
non madame elles ne sont pas brûlés non
ça peut servir donc encore
mais monsieur soir notre candidat numéro
je pensais à l'effet de la main parce
que vous êtes à plat sur la boîte
d'allumettes
oui et quand vous la montée un peu le
coach veut vous pouvez pas retirer sur
vous rejoignez donc notre ami candidat
numéro 2 n'est ce pas qui vous a parlé
de mouvements de la main et n'a pas
réussi mais avec la force des machines
comme ça vous l'avons m'est venue mais
je venais venin sur leurs micros
messieurs vous avez l'air d'avoir
vraiment une solution très au point
alors écoutez on ne sait jamais ça peut
marcher très bien allez-y méchoui avec
le cheveu mais on vient me dire qu'il y
avait pas de cheveux c'est ça le
problème
il n'y a pas de cheveux monsieur mais
vous vous en avez beaucoup par contre
alors des dons ça pourrait nous être
utile à mais c'est pas ça merci monsieur
candidat numéro 6 une question à poser à
gérard oui est-ce que vous attachez le
dessus de la boîte d'allumettes à votre
main avec un ruban adhésif ruban adhésif
qui seraient attachées dessus au dessus
de la boîte d'allumettes et sur votre
poignet écouter non monsieur je
n'utilise pas je suis obligé de répondre
très précisément à votre question je
n'utilise pas du ruban adhésif pour
faire ce tour bien et bien demain gérard
notre tout nouveau truc la boîte
sympathique vaudra 900 francs le voici
notre tout nouveau truc qui est d'un
amateur monsieur lafon au pied du mur et
ses nouveaux trucs vaut 300 francs
regardez bien vous récepteur
jean lafon professeur de boxe française
nous a écrit pour nous présenter un truc
très et man il y a neuf à vous présenter
un mouvement qui va vous paraître très
facile vous mettez face au mur vous
comptez 3par à partir du mur
voilà les pieds l'un derrière l'autre
vous joignez les deux pieds vous
fléchissez sur l'avant en appuyant la
tête contre le mur
vous prenez le tabouret ici vous le
coller à la poitrine
et vous allez-vous relevé sans décoller
les talons ni fléchir les jambes pour
l'instant ce n'est pas très étonnant qu
effectivement pour les femmes c'est très
facile mais pour les hommes c'est
impossible et pourtant il ya un truc qui
permet à tous les hommes de réussir ce
mouvement alors monsieur pour 300 francs
j'espère que vous allez découvrir ce
truc une question à poser à gérard majax
au départ est ce qu'il ya une des
questions de différence de morphologie
entre entre la femme et l'homme à
monsieur oui sur cette question je peux
vous dire qu'il existe une différence
qui permet le écoutez monsieur
évidemment il y a une chose qui jouent
et sûr à votre question je suis obligé
de répondre oui
est ce que ça vous donne une idée de
solutions non moi je vous réponds oui
vous me répondez non à des dents un fait
normand peut-être notre candidat numéro
de monsieur mailly faut-il laisser le
bruit collé contre son corps ah non le
tabouret au départ est posé vous l'avez
vu au pied du mur d'où le titre et on le
soulève vers la poitrine avant de se
relever
vous l'avez vu ça je le dis pour nos
amis téléspectateurs avant l'émission
on a fait essayer nos candidats
effectivement une dame qui est candidate
numéro 4 a essayé a réussi et le
monsieur numéro a essayé n'a pas réussi
mais tous les hommes ne peuvent pas le
faire
candidat numéro 3 monsieur madani une
question à poser est ce que ce qu'a dit
notre ami le candidat numéro 2 qui
apparemment ne donnaient pas lieu à une
solution vous peut vous aider et non pas
spécialement
est ce qu'elle est ce que les fai de
prendre les tabourets contre les
batteries n'est fait quelque chose
oui monsieur c'est ce qui empêche
justement de pouvoir se relever mais
pourquoi seulement chez un homme madame
ajax notre candidate numéro 4 vous êtes
la seule femme de cette émission je le
répète et vous vous devez pouvoir
arriver vous avez réussi avant
l'émission madame ou la vessie et vous
avez monsieur n'a pas pu alors qu'est ce
que vous appelez une histoire de gens me
des rats des reins vous pensez que
en se relevant tout doucement on arrive
à remonter le tabouret alors vous pensez
qu'un monsieur pourrait essayer
eh bien écoutez nous nous nous voulons
bien essayé alors avec un monsieur
on va demander à nos deux derniers
candidats est ce qu'ils ont une solution
mais si eva je pensais aux chaussures
parce que son mollet au talon et aux
échanges
et oui monsieur évidemment ça pourrait
déséquilibrer le corps et les penché en
avant c'est à ça que vous pensiez
monsieur et bien non monsieur ce n'est
pas cela et vous monsieur est candidat
numéro 6 monsieur clamagirand est ce que
c'est une question de position des bras
en portant tabouret qui fait qu'une
femme ne mettra les bras plus long du
corps ou ah non non non monsieur de
position vous voulez dire dans la façon
de tenir les oreilles d'avoir les bras à
la position non monsieur ce n'est pas la
solution de monsieur jean lafon mais
pour terminer je voudrais bien quand
même que l'un des messieurs qui n'a pas
encore essayé pour bien prouver à nos
téléspectateurs que ce n'est pas
possible pour un monsieur bien venir
essayer monsieur vous voulez bien tenez
venez par ici je n'ai pas ici nous avons
un mur solide et ça vous savez c'est
difficile dans les constructions
modernes à trouver mais il n'y a pas de
problème monsieur à partir s'il vous
plaît
du mime fait un pas deux pas trois pas
derrière les deux pieds d'un côté
l'autre non 3,3 seulement voilà le
tabouret la voulez vous vous blessez
appuyer votre tête s'il vous plaît sur
le mur levé le tabouret à la poitrine
essayez de vous relever vous ne pouvez
pas monsieur voyez eh bien c'était une
preuve pour nous inviter les spectateurs
bravo monsieur eh bien demain au pied du
mur le truc de monsieur lafon voudra 600
francs et la boîte sympathique 900
francs on se retrouve demain il n'y a
pas beaucoup d'aller mettre dans cette
boîte
suffisamment pour réaliser un petit os
très étrange
il faut prendre le petit cheveu voilà et
là maintenant arriver à faire monter la
boîte
évidemment si je tire le fil le cheveu
dans l'autre sens la voix tombe au
pardon j'oubliais qui est un truc jean
lafon professeur de boxe française nous
a écrit pour nous présenter un truc très
et man il y a d'la vous présentez un
mouvement qui va vous paraître très
facile vous mettez face au mur vous
comptez 3par à partir du mur on a les
pieds l'un derrière l'autre vous joignez
les deux pieds vous fléchissez sur
l'avant en appuyant la tête contre le
mur
vous prenez le tabouret ici vous le
coller à la poitrine
et vous allez-vous relevé sans décoller
les talons ni fléchir les jambes pour
l'instant ce n'est pas très étonnant qu
effectivement pour les femmes c'est très
facile mais pour les hommes c'est
impossible et pourtant et un truc qui
permet à tous les hommes de réussir ce
mouvement
[Musique]